it's your fault if your business isn't
where you want it to be it's your fault
and it's on you to fix it hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and if your
business is not the level that you think
it deserves to be then it's on you to
get in there and fix it it's not because
your employees suck or your customers
suck or because of the government or
because of the economy or because of
whatever excuse you're telling yourself
fill in the blank if you want your
business to do better you have to accept
responsibility for where it is today
it's your fault it's on you to make it
better as long as you keep telling
yourself a story as to why your business
isn't bigger as long as you believe that
story it's always going to hold you back
nobody is coming to save you you have to
make this right you have to accept
responsibility and build the business
that you deserve to have take action
today good luck if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up below and hey
I want to hear from you please leave a
comment under the video thanks guys
we'll see you soon
you